>> THERE IS A NEW MOM IN TOWN,
TALKER.
>> Tucker: WE NEED ONE,
THANK YOU.
SO IN LOS ANGELES, GEORGE SOROS
FUNDED GEORGE HAS GONE AND
STOPPED ENFORCING LAWS AGAINST
THEFT.
WHAT YOU THINK HAPPENED THEN?
WELL, THEFT WENT OUT.
PEOPLE WERE STEALING EVERYWHERE.
A FEW DAYS AGO, A THIEF STOLE
$3 MILLION FROM A SINGLE SHOP IN
BEVERLY HILLS.
BUT INSTEAD OF STOPPING THESE
CRIMINALS, THEY ARE TELLING
RESIDENTS, JUST DON'T WEAR
JEWELRY.
HERE'S THE POLICE CHIEF OF L.A.
>> THERE'S BEEN A MARKED
INCREASE INVOLVING VICTIMS OF
WHEREIN EXPENSIVE JEWELRY.
WHAT WE ARE ASKING THE PUBLIC TO
DO IS THAT WITH THESE INCREASES
IF THEY'RE GOING TO WEAR
EXPENSIVE JEWELRY OR INVOLVED IN
PERHAPS DRIVING HIGH-END CARS,
LEAVING RESTAURANTS, TAVERNS,
AND OTHER LOCATIONS, THAT THEY
BE MINDFUL OF THEIR
SURROUNDINGS.
THEY REMAIN IN WELL-LIT AREAS.
THAT YOU RECOGNIZE THAT THERE
ARE OPPORTUNISTS ATTEMPTED TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THEM.
AND MANY TIMES THESE INDIVIDUALS
ARE ARMED WITH A FIREARM.
>> Tucker: YES.
JOHN PHILLIPS STRESSES TONIGHT
FOR THE QUEUE FOR COMING ON.
HOW IS WHAT WE JUST ARE
DIFFERENT FROM A COP SAME LOOK,
THERE IS A OUT, DON'T LOOK HOT.
NO SPANDEX FOR YOU.
YOU MIGHT INSIGHT HIM.
HE IS BLAMING PEOPLE FOR WEARING
JEWELRY IN PUBLIC.
>> THIS IS THEIR ATTITUDE.
WE HAVE A SOROS DISTRICT
ATTORNEY, WE HAVE A MAYOR WHO
CUT THEIR BUDGET, WE HAVE A
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS WHO WENT TO
WAR WITH OUR SHERIFF, AND WANTS
TO GET RID OF A CENTRAL JAIL AND
JUVENILE HALL SO EVEN IF WE HAVE
ARREST PEOPLE, WE HAVE NO PLACE
TO PUT THEM.
SURPRISE, SURPRISE, L.A. COUNTY
LOOKS LIKE THE DEPARTURES GATE
OVER AT SPIRIT AIRLINES.
AND IT IS NOT JUST IN THE
TRADITIONAL HIGH CRIME AREAS
WERE ALL THIS IS GOING ON.
IT IS HAPPENING IN SAUNA DOME
SANTA MONICA, BEVERLY HILLS
PRAYER THEY'RE GOING AFTER BIG
TICKET ITEMS.
ROLEX WATCHES, LUXURY CARS, AND
JUST TODAY ON THE RADIO SHOW,
SHOW, ADD A LISTENER: WHO SAID
THAT HE WAS ROBBED AT GUNPOINT
IN THE PARKING LOT OF COSTCO IN
MARINA DEL REY, VERY NICE PART
OF LOS ANGELES.
THE THIEVES DIDN'T TAKE ANYTHING
THAT SAID KIRKLAND ON IT, THEY
TOOK VERY EXPENSIVE WATCH.
THIS IS WHAT WE LIVE WITH.
THE COPS SAY, DON'T DRIVE THE
FANCY CAR.
PEOPLE DON'T MOVE TO CALIFORNIA
TO LOOK FRUMPY AND BE LATE.
THEY MOVE HERE TO BE FASHIONABLE
AND BE LATE.
>> Tucker: [LAUGHS]
GREAT LINE.
WHOSE COUNTRY IS IT?
THE PEOPLE WHO PAY THE TAXES OR
DOES IT DO BLOCKED ALL NOT
HOMELESS DRUG ADDICTS AND
ROBBERS.
WHY ARE ACCOMMODATING THEM?
SHOULD THIS GET THAT OFF THE
STREET.
>> THEY LOOK AT THE CRIMINAL IS
THE VICTIM.
AND IF YOU ARE THE VICTIM OF A
CRIME, THEY WANT YOU TO CHECK
YOUR PRIVILEGE.
THEY HAVE EVERYTHING
UPSIDE DOWN.
WHAT IS RIGHT IS WRONG, WHAT IS
WRONG IS RIGHT.
BUT THAT IS WHAT THE POLITICAL
ESTABLISHMENT HERE THANKS FROM
TOP TO BOTTOM.
FROM THE MAYOR, THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY, THE POLICE CHIEF, THE
WHOLE COUNTY NEEDS A CHANGE.
>> IT IS A PUNISHMENT, YOU ARE
EXACTLY RIGHT.
THAT IS WHAT EQUIT